here's how Microsoft teams became the
king of video conferencing Microsoft
launched teams in 2017 and by the end of
the year teams only had a 2 million
users 2019 was a much better year for
teams as they finally got into the tens
of millions of users but the
Breakthrough obviously didn't come until
2020. as we all know 2020 forced
everyone to reevaluate their video
conferencing Solutions and the choice
was pretty clear Doom or teams both
products offered leading conferencing
Solutions but teams had a slight leg up
on Zoom which was integration with the
Microsoft's other products for companies
that already relied on Microsoft
products this energy was simply too good
to pass on